uh tuvalu seeks the floor i give the
floor to the loo
thank you
mr president
glasgow has delivered a strong message
of hope
a strong message of promise
glasgow has delivered a strong message
of ambition
what is left now
is for us to deliver
on that promise
i sympathize with the honorable
gentleman from the european union who
yesterday
showed us
the photo of his grandson
i too
am a grandfather of three
little
children
and i keep looking at their photos
every single night after returning from
these hawks
thinking
what would i tell them
upon my return from glasgow
i will now be able to tell them that
glasgow
has made a promise
to secure them their future
that will be the best ever christmas
gift
i will present to them
we have now embarked on the glasgow
train
the glasgow train of ambition
the glasgow train of 1.5 degrees
climate change is real
there is no politics in climate change
so my fellow political leaders
our response to climate change should
never depend
on whether our domestic response to
climate change would get us re-elected
in the next elections
responding to climate change is critical
to our survival of our communities
the survival of humanity
it is not and should never be linked to
our political survival in the next
elections
so friends
we urge all countries to board
this glasgow train
we need to continue to work hard
to keep this glasgow train moving and
moving fast
so we can reach the next cop at egypt
and deliver on that glasgow train of
ambition and 1.5 degrees
so in closing mr president
we thank glasgow
we thank the prime minister
boris johnson and your presidency
alex sharma and your team
for your able leadership and we thank
glasgow for keeping us safe
friends
glasgow ends today
but the real work begins now
we must now deliver on the glasgow train
of ambition and 1.5 thank you all
[Applause]